back up my broccolini get your life
together
I'm not touching
you definitely bro no get away from me
higher I do yeah no I run here from New
Orleans
I run here oh I thought you did yeah
you're crazy man have you ever been
around yourself mm not a time did you
should get one of these you should get a
mirror that's real clear and [ __ ] me
yeah better friends what's going on her
dress is you in the morning he'd better
friends yeah I dress myself I set this
out last night no yeah dude what were
you doing in New Orleans but what do you
uh I was hanging out my family all saw
Dustin Poirier dude let me hold the
straps God get off his nerve my god
Dustin I apologize ma'am he doesn't hang
out so he wins the bell oh my god God
nice I apologize Dustin like this guy
thank you guy like you know we're gonna
fight for 90 years all of a sudden
you're on his dick hole dude he fought
Bill Clinton early in his career bro it
doesn't haunt and everybody and first of
all we are from the same country bro I
don't know because do you first of all
you're the guy who dressed like that one
of the dudes that Michael Jackson
molested Wade Robson today I just like
him I'll get my Kanye West's gospel
meetings I'm sorry
I like the early I'll [ __ ] well you look
like Coach Ella bro thank you well you
look like you coach a freakin one of the
weakest wrestling teams and [ __ ] in
Beverly Hills hi I'm coach Ella you look
like Billy Ray Cyrus's agent no you look
you gotta get a good look at yourself
man do you need better friends you just
like nah that ain't about him and he
can't dress like a character
you look like a referee at Hot Topic bro
that's how you're dressed right now bro
you like the head referee the line judge
and a hot topic dude you look like
security for Toys R Us security for a
yard sale you dress like the time do
that route routes for the [ __ ] White
Walkers you have no idea what Game of
Thrones yeah I do man I've been to Game
of Thrones it's a place where they sell
toilet or a toilets isn't it correct
also formerly known as Spencer's yeah
dude I remember going to Spencer's and
stealing a bunch of [ __ ] from there dude
bro and what about our idea that that we
still haven't made yet lava lamps that
have Siemens you Boston uh-huh and you
can ejaculate into the lamp and
contribute to the beauty of your own
environment and then I'm talking about
the praise God kind of like a chia pet
yeah full of [ __ ] well you'd have to say
come break it's a seam and you could say
ski because they something less you'd
yeah you can see it's less harsh
yeah bro ski then come what is this on
I'm sorry would you grow up with a
little John as your teacher okay Steve
first of all most shocked the world
right now can we get a picture up of a
little John Winnie without his
sunglasses oh man he is an ugly-looking
he's not ugly bro is a very unique style
in his eyes I would say that Oh does he
have crazy eyes huh
does he have uh the chameleon no he's
got that built-in crossing guard back
behind his nose somewhere dude he's that
Wildcat but you gotta love him man it's
Little John and it just goes to show you
man you gotta trust no it's the one of
the tuxedo go up man look it's a
yearbook one right there oh that's not
him no John no it's not yeah it is bro
oh yeah he was taking he's getting an
eye exam that guy's like okay what's on
that line he's like why oh one or two
yeah dude and the problem is a lot of
kids learn me that's how they you know
answer on tests and stuff
it's very sad it's a problem
but yeah his eyes yeah man he can see
from here was one of his eyes was his
abut he was it was a birth eye and then
the other one I think was donated at
some point oh he bought it was it make
sense yeah he got that off cuz he has
one birth I know that he has one ha ha
ha was New Orleans huh how was New
Orleans it was good man what do we do a
lot a ting a lot of foods went down
there for the holiday Eastern went there
for the Easter is your family religious
yeah we went to church I mean we got a
little bit of the church oh yeah let you
in looking for the Lord yeah oh wow yeah
did you just stay outside and put your
ear to the door no joke during the
service uh the somebody was singing on
the stage you know and you always have
that drummer that's like behind the key
though oh oh yeah like what is going on
he's behind like the plastic wall Sasson
a tour he's the president is that weird
glass yes important bro the church drama
though it's too much too much um did you
start I don't like men no I don't like
men in her mouth sometimes that spear to
get you yeah he gets me
yeah the fear of wild man is fair wild
and he uh but no he gave a buzz buzz out
from the stage I think I'm the only one
that caught the reference you know how
awkward is it when I've been searching
forever but I was embarrassed
obviously dude I didn't know you look
like Satan's a little [ __ ] you dressed
like Satan's a little [ __ ] crack pipe
and handed out Scientology box still
[ __ ] you look like you're giving
discounts on Scientology books
dude I look at you guy knows how to bag
leaves you know what I'm saying bro dude
but you know any of the songs do you
know any designs um oh yeah I know some
of the songs you really well they put
the words up there in like seven
thousand five or you want the screen you
want that fancy one yeah this church is
pretty it's pretty fancy it's right on
me LSU campus I don't know what it's
called
but we had fun dude the pastor named
Kevin he's real chill bruh big cast
touching kids and [ __ ] still no no no he
has kids of his own so at that point I
mean you could touch alright he's not
doing anything like that though he's on
the you never know Louisiana Christiana
what are you talking about dude they got
it guys two crawdads football molest
kids ha ha ha ha oh dude that's here
dude no that's not his alley would
Hollywood what are you talking about
this some guy across town Pro probably
having his son for lunch bro this place
Holly was a shadiest day music game ends
up there in the Hills yeah man oh and
they're buying straight children off the
internet and eat and write movies and
[ __ ] it's crazy out here it's the dark
heart what how was your boy Dustin
Poirier the diamond monkey the diamond
was doing good bro he actually was
eating doughnuts I will say that Ruby I
don't know if you know I don't know how
that could affect his future who's not
eating doughnuts who could be far bro
first of all they don't have doughnuts
and khabib the country okay they seem
like a right quikrete for breakfast they
[ __ ] eat they eat concrete well dude
there probably are they're using
steroids as we call them brother the
steroids I mean these are they're
they're so Airy look at my beads knob
but they're definitely they're the ones
that started this whole chin has turned
into an armpit have you seen could be I
have yeah it's insane trouble but did he
did let me pick up the strap or he did
and I [ __ ] drop the bow it's heavy
dude now which belt is better the final
kid guest of the year or that belt well
first of all he actually said bro why
didn't you bring your belt and I said
because those [ __ ] creeps having
given it to me studio walk by every day
you could just stop in let me know what
it's it's him bro I got you months ago
okay
Santino got his award oh yeah rookie
here oh it's a goddamn Oscar the red
Adam right that's how they call that guy
that [ __ ] whiskey ginger the guy's an
alcoholic dude that Kyle died in a drunk
driving accident any day now oh yeah
come by and get it should we start this
this [ __ ]
hey we got a Kingston Mertz dropping
Friday Friday Friday we took six monster
hand-making
like to do it all myself Oh what I've
been doing man I leave here print shirts
that's a great question actually really
that's awesome may I do Rosy's I've seen
the touch me tease the regular King the
sting tease well look since some of
those don't touch me tees down to
Florida for children dude because a lot
of PDF files down there and also up here
in East Hollywood here on the websites
King the sting calm yeah some mutant
bought the King in the sting really yeah
so we at King the sting calm why yeah I
mean King and the sting King the sting
calm but why didn't someone get King and
this thing
yeah so I just told you some dude bought
it way before us some some mutant we
found where he's at he's in Australia
nah yeah anyone give it up won't give it
up and then when you click on it it goes
to other comics websites no way cater
the sting calm King the sting calm
unbelievable not surprised that you
[ __ ] left a word out of a sentence
bro tell you what bro unbelievable
Brendan all right let's get him barely
even stand being here you didn't bring
me a coffee this one had to make one
when I confit bro and how about we
poured that cream in the refrigerator oh
this this [ __ ] use pee cream like the
vegetable pee and it's all clumpy yeah
it makes me sick oh it was so gross dude
imagine you're ready to see crew
bro quit creaming things first of all
these [ __ ] out here in
Hollywood
excuse the nut melt bro it's not in your
mouth no I don't but at some point it's
a lot of these PDF files out here if you
want a buck and drink something out of a
child drink it out of a [ __ ] child
quit getting all these young [ __ ]
vegetables it says on there like young
eggplant milk and you're like what the
[ __ ] is going on do you ever had
Parmesan cheese milk huh
it's too much it's [ __ ] this up but dude
I turn the pee milk over and it had a
huge clump of something came off the uh
it was so disturbing two inches around
bro oh I mean a straight it looked like
a damn nut off of a damn uh maybe a
dolphin or something some support the
podcast here's an ad a deal man when you
need red wine at 4 p.m. or sushi at 9
p.m. or maybe need a wet burrito at 8
a.m. whatever you need bro postmates sit
post mate dude I got I actually got post
mates last night and I don't usually get
post mates but sometimes I do
is it nice like a little assistant who
I'm hungry boom comes right to your door
I was starving last night and I was like
oh who would bring me over something
look at that they got a man on a magical
bicycle and boom you don't have to rely
on a friend in him next thing you know
sushi in my mouth at 11:00 p.m. what bro
24 hours a day 365 days a year
so she's not kita but we'll figure it
out post mates we'll bring you whatever
you need within an hour no more trips of
the story don't you need to know where
the store is that post mates will do it
all for you and this is perfect for a
guy like Brendan cuz Brendan would get
lost doing anything and sashimi's keto
though isn't it
uh kind of man it's fish if it's just
fish that's all you eat is fish just
fish then you're good yeah
you look like you just fishing carrots
really yeah yeah great body dude I
ordered a batch of minnows right out of
that guy that's in in that video you
just be ill what I want to know is 24
hours a day 365 days a year you can get
post nice is that right that's right
dude and for a limited time post mates
is given the Kingston listeners $100 of
free delivery that's a lot to start your
free deliveries download the app
obviously and use the code cat K ATS
2019 yep that's K 80s 2:01 9 k 80s 2 0 1
9 for $100 for free delivery credit for
your first 7 days anything you need
anytime you need postmates it download
post mates and save with the code cats
2019 yep
support the podcast k 80s 2 0 1 9 thank
you trying to keep lights on
well I'll say this
Robin Hood is an investing app that lets
you buy and sell stocks ETFs options and
Kryptos all commission-free
true that man while other brokerages can
charge up to ten dollars for every trade
Robin Hood doesn't charge any Commission
fees so you can trade stocks and keep
all of your prop keep it all plus there
is no account minimum deposit needed to
get started so you can start investing
at any level you learn the simple design
of Robin and makes it so easy to invest
for newcomers and experts alike tell
them or view easy to understand charts
and market data and place trade in just
four tabs for your smartphone yeah yeah
you can also view stock collections such
as 100 most popular yep with Robin Hood
you can learn how to invest in the
market as you build your portfolio
discover new stocks track your favorite
companies and get custom notifications
for price movements so you never miss
the right moment to invest in Robin Hood
is given the listeners of King Yemma
sting a free stock like Apple Ford or
sprint get a free hitter
what up to help you build your profile
right now sign up at King sting dot
Robin Hood com
that's king sting Robin Hood dot-com
someone's got to pay for britain's
coffee habit we're gonna start it off
with debate club today
we got Derrick in here today Derrick
poke at it that's true everybody you
know very young I love everybody and
they actually have a very similar skin
tone Derrick and cash oh wow you think I
don't a little bit oh I don't
Wow beautiful yeah hmm thank you yeah
you're welcome brother appreciate it
we're gonna start welcome Adam fresh
from church so nicer I do
I'll get the feeling in me dude hey
juice you got that hey Suz drip thanks
Wade Robson dude that obviously got
molested by Michael Jackson and then did
it was a pseudo kid it will just
steroids to try to act like you didn't
grow you look like Wade Robson and
carrot top had a [ __ ] kid if you are
Jack Brown you're like Billy Ray Cyrus
and [ __ ] Amanda Bynes and a child
whatever that [ __ ] crazy [ __ ]
mullet but let's be honest though and
this is a this may be a cry for help or
I don't know how you cry for help at
someone who may need it but let's just
admit that Pete Davidson is turning into
the tall Amanda Bynes can we do that I
like I like Pete - that's also not
discredit the fact that someone could be
having mental health issues you might be
the person that doesn't reach out to
somebody I'm serious man I reached out
to him and what'd he say
nothing yeah okay I'm not your guru yeah
well I'm not taking life advice and Theo
lindsay lohan dead look how she turned
that first of all I did slip a note
under her door we stayed in the same
hotel like 13 years ago you're trying to
[ __ ] oh yeah yeah and don't [ __ ] touch
me 13 years ago she was bugging in
before she got all crazy and skinny yeah
okay the big tits and right now Pete
Davidson's bangin Berlin I'm saying he's
talking Beckinsale bro
yeah bro Kate Beckinsale's banged all of
our young friends first of all well yeah
cool
there's no problem with it I agree I
like her oh I think that geez hon oh so
he's electing Ronde children bro I'm
just saying he's turning into the tall
Amanda Bynes when is it in well Amanda
ballons got a [ __ ] together
all right grew her hair back out she's a
tall took 11 years to took 11 years had
to give out the business took 11 years
man I mean look I love Pete Davidson but
I just wonder is he still doing comedy
this point what is he doing he does he's
doing movies now it's Judd Apatow well
yes audition is he still doing comedy
that was what I wanted a just stand up
you know I'm not talking about civil
rights with Judd Apatow okay
I'm talking about comedy anyway I just
hope that Pete's okay I want to let him
know that I that I do wonder if he's
okay or not because a lot of it seems
like a cry for help for me somehow Oh
career you know he was dying his hair
different colors for a while men with a
head he was ariana grande's mood ring
you know I'm saying you could tell us
she was feeling based on his hair color
it's true and I woke up yeah and then
what now he's dating a woman a senior
citizen almost Reese and oh she bad
though I agree but a pre senior said you
trying to start a beef with Pete huh you
try to start a feeling baby mama TV
comedy be VP I love feet I'm just saying
I am I am concerned concerned about him
yeah I'm concerned about his bank
account yeah that's fine bro he'll be
able to afford a very nice funeral if he
doesn't take care of himself
that's all I'm saying it's just bro it's
scary and it looks like he's getting
into a scary place maybe he's not you
know they caught him at he was sitting
on the top of a [ __ ] scaffolding in a
[ __ ] Nine Inch Nails concert maybe
he's doing fine okay okay that's a cry
for help
that's Brendon that [ __ ] Train
concert hanging on top of the bleachers
you know it's about time for the head
we're no good all sure you should worry
you are Daryl Smith yeah [ __ ] Nick
shows up with Aerosmith concert shirt I
like there it's like [ __ ] 1987
premature Nick brooches only shirt dude
the guy goes terrible yeah yo dude I
clothed my guys unlike chin who's in
here wearing some [ __ ] concentration
kids kids ballin she came here with a
[ __ ] gold pinkie ring what the [ __ ]
he really did great in from work on bat
he's got a rap video oh he's definitely
got that Shawshank Redemption lift kit
bro he's got a pinkie ring he's [ __ ]
got the wardens music all right Romano
from upstate New York clean brawling
sweet [ __ ] tattoo of the Darth Vader
I like that man I got looks clean I was
[ __ ] a clean young man up there and
upstate New York hard to stay clean up
there dish I don't have a lot of soap up
there well shout out to everybody in
recovery well what I'm saying is this
man uh what was it was yes April on me
April O'Neill from Teenage Mutant Ninja
Turtles
Jean Grey which is rogue now April had
some tittays but [ __ ] rogue was that
body was bangin bro Jean Grae bro here's
the thing about April O'Neill she just
owned five Turtles she was a slave owner
also she never let none of them [ __ ]
ever my damn dog was always trying to
[ __ ] no Michelangelo was constantly
trying to [ __ ] she always blue balls
those boys well who by boys I mean five
grown Turtles
first of all April O'Neill all day dude
that thing is a one-piece that she's
wearing brush it is hot and she always
just had that camera she was always
ready to shoot her own porn at the house
Loki van Hoorn she was in a van by
herself with a camera dude looking to
[ __ ] she basically drive an executive
producer for bangbus she was way before
her time dude April lineal beautiful
hard worker obviously had a degree who's
this other human trap house that you got
over here from here gray what's the
other one's name jean grey bro also over
this road she looks like it came out the
same character no Jean Grey and rogue
are two different characters yeah don't
touch my eyes are up different my dad
told me that are the same so definitely
you're dead Michael Jackson dude boy the
[ __ ] never lands for wearing the
Neverland Ranch [ __ ] workout kid so
that's so Rogan Jean Grey aren't the no
bro look take you've done with April and
Neil like you've been going to the gym
with Tevin Campbell dude you gotta
[ __ ] tighten up man you just need to
give energy yeah I will buy you a gym
membership I'm trying to my hips are
hurting a lot recently you creep from
what I have dysplasia you idiots from
what bro from collecting hamsters dude I
did a lot of ground-and-pound when I was
young man growing up in the mean streets
of without streets there were dirt roads
you idiot the mean dirt roads I mean to
her small who's this other frickin
that's rogue bro [ __ ] Road you know what
rogue you know she thought she was all
fancy with other mutants and ship for
the x-men [ __ ] the x-men I'm [ __ ] a
brony all day I agree with you she's
down with the van - [ __ ] she owned five
Turtles slave owner but whatever rogue
it's not slavery dude if they're
reptiles are not a yes I true they were
they did have personalities and they did
love pizza
well they fought for a [ __ ] they
fought for pizza they fought for a rat
for peace they fought a rat in the rap a
diamond pizza they're like IKEA slave
owners
they're lucky anybody give a [ __ ] about
him dude they're Turtles fighting for a
rat dude Ninja Turtles they were turtles
that new [ __ ] ninjutsu okay it's easy
to learn oh wow ninjutsu first of all
being an actual mom she inspired you
you're the Rat King yeah teach me Ninja
Turtles oh that's what we're tracking
they're bringing my abs were this all
originated from that's what the Rat King
came from I know where I came from I
three row Jesus Christ I can't even
believe someone let you get a GED
that's splinter and he's hard as [ __ ]
yeah that splinter so Derek's [ __ ]
about to get laid off look oh no Rat
King did I've been ratting into Turtles
of course that's a ranking right there
it's a group of rats heads that band
together to survive that's exactly what
it is but let me get him to this other
person rogue or whatever this lady's
name Trap House [ __ ] Ron or whatever
this lady's I thought bro she's uh an
afterthought for me dude
she's like a G model looks like carrot
top with [ __ ] freezer burn brothers
[ __ ] looks oh she looks crust it out
dude and what she is what does she win
is that an outfit is that paint
April's old school she's classy bro she
has a job she goes back to her apartment
this other [ __ ] [ __ ] probably
looks like she sleeps in the freezer
section at Ralph's bro bro but she also
looks like you remember she lives in a
[ __ ]
the xmin house with Professor X doing
god-knows-what that's true there's six
other dudes around all the time you
don't think she's gonna [ __ ] train
Ramabai the other mutants oh I don't
think thank God he was [ __ ] doing work
don't think like yeah then you know the
x-men bro you think you hang around the
guy named the beasts and Wolverine and
no one's can dick down in that house oh
yeah dude and the turtles were respect
well you know yeah [ __ ] together they
live by this samurai so I'm going with
April O'Neill I'm going with April
O'Neill first of all it's easy to be a
ninja these days you don't even is there
any real training you just have to wear
a costume hide underground the one guy
had sighs those little thing that's not
even a [ __ ] weapon dude let's see
more Scott what is that for you weird
turtle you'd be Michelangelo you know
that yeah yeah that's what the stick
isn't it ah Michelangelo is the one the
orange one what did were his weapons Oh
nunchucks
I'm sorry Donatello why do young purple
guy yeah check it out I do
dye my tell her cuz I'm a [ __ ] dime
boy bebop bebop and rocksteady brulee is
bro April a lot basically two percent of
people say rogue wow your [ __ ] look
I've never trusted our fan base
disturbing Kelly Crosby and baby
Campbell from Arizona
Oh maybe got front to look at them Todd
huh hey guys debate club question what
is scarier ghosts or aliens gang gang
buzz buzz oh my god is that [ __ ]
who's cute man lady is cute in the buzz
Bryan Callen she had something on her
back
it's a beautiful young man um well what
is she God broke my spirit what's
scarier ghosts or aliens ghosts or
aliens [ __ ] aliens this is a easy one
yeah deal ghost what's the worst they
can do I don't know [ __ ] with my lights
might pull my sheets back okay cool man
somebody told me once in a dream that
aliens are gonna come here and fight
black people is that crazier what did a
white person tell you that no I don't
remember who it was but I mean otherwise
that there's a low-key beef between
aliens and black people yeah we know
about Mexicans
what yeah bro I don't think so dude told
you this no Maurice Clarett told me the
most dangerous people in prison are
Mexicans that they are the cartel people
yeah the movie I was coming from a black
guy so no somebody told me there's beef
between black people and aliens dude I'm
not a bi person I'm an insider-trading
year I don't know so let's go to our
let's go to our ethnic friends that are
here right now are you suing cats or
Derick or scared of aliens because
they're black I don't know if anyone's
scared of them I'm saying is there a
low-key beef between ethnicities that
aren't white I'm white I don't know we
have beef against certain things when we
like we have what do white people have
beef against I would say probably money
taxes water slow internet um I don't
know what chrome wire uses are know a
lot of white people like them I don't
think none otherwise I don't hang out
that's true
me neither what do you think dare are
you scared of aliens I just wanna know
Theo did you get that information from
the movie independence can see Will
Smith punch a play punched an alien
you're like oh there's beef aliens and
he's kind of the leader I don't know
what I was watching but I fell asleep
Ben had a dream that and I'm and then it
started to resonate with me that there
is a Loki thing going on between black
people and aliens at and I wouldn't know
about it you wouldn't know about it you
know I think we refer to aliens you mean
Mexicans I think that's good no I'm
talking about area legally I'm talking
about air aliens are you talking about
like area 50 yeah you know what I'm
saying so Derek you ever heard of this
so-called beef I mean no Theo
okay I'm not accusing anybody just one
black guy though said it so that's where
you get to them you know that well I'd
say this the first time black people
have a lot of early information because
first time I learned about Flat Earth I
was at a pizza place a late night pizza
[ __ ] spot at a casino he told me this
and two black dudes said hey man we got
to talk to you right and I thought you
know [ __ ] was about to go down you know
like they were gonna run a train on you
know oh you thought you were gonna beat
you up I didn't know I wasn't sure I'm
ready to do that our gamble together
talked about [ __ ]
racial problem I don't have me that well
no dude we'll talk about flatter well
that's what they did they stand on the
beat of a parlor and which is irony cuz
you're in a pizza parlor right and so
the P to that whole set up and that's
the way they said look man look at this
pizza what do you think about it saying
I was like it's there like they said is
around and I said I mean it's round but
they said but really is flat and they
these dudes explain to me Flat Earth and
I'd never heard it before and then years
later Flat Earth comes to be this big
thing you know they just you know you
know they're doing all a flat everything
for dummies but yeah I guess it's a big
thing big name for thinkers I think but
now to hear that black people in aliens
are against each other
I can i I don't know if that's real
that's why I'm trying to flat earthers
I'm not having it from you to you is but
I don't know where you got that from
okay I believe you there might be some
truth there though I think you're I
think you're looking fused and are you
hearing anything on your front cat yeah
I know that okay I'm glad we got that
out of the way pull down dude Wow
yeah I can't stand other agents no it's
crazy though is you never hear Asians
with conspiracy 30s right aliens they
don't give a [ __ ] you have a lot of no
really give that ghost force to wherever
the [ __ ] we're like yes there's ghosts
there yeah well that's logan paul did
that yeah i know and i think he killed
his brother or there's some what
happened they stumbled oh yeah well look
man I think you just don't [ __ ] with the
conspiracy theories in like flatter [ __ ]
they're too busy make making [ __ ] what
do you mean making [ __ ] do you mean dude
what do you mean you're the one wearing
all this [ __ ] they're making I know so
are you as made in America you it's not
it is all son I'm way more scared of
aliens [ __ ] ghost what's the worst
thing that ghosts can do to you
ghosts can haunt you ghosts can possess
your grandmother kudos man give her some
energy goes can live at your
grandparents house forever yeah they
just hot old people I'm amazed we
haven't seen as many ghosts recently as
there
in LA there's no ghost I definitely see
at the Comedy Store go in the belly room
turn the lights off shit's definitely
honk if that's a guy feeling on you dude
is it [ __ ] damn ghost
butters a gay ghost but yeah I'll go
aliens because they're like the bigger
ghosts they're like ghosts daddy you
know and we don't know what they're
doing they're out there they might come
by they might not but dude I'll tell you
this I'd watch a group of aliens and a
group of brothers [ __ ] throw down in
today of the week yeah you keep going
back to aliens versus black guys and I
don't mean because I heard a really fun
video game but I heard early information
aliens versus black guys the video game
yeah I play that dude good don't ah dude
that's a good dude you hit me right in
one of my carpet side dude talk to poor
me about it
51% of people said aliens [ __ ] hey ghost
what are they gonna do our next one but
if you hear anything Derek let us know
you know I gotta keep us on that front
just text me next one called from Cody
from Anaheim oh [ __ ] power here Cody
gang gang buzz-buzz it's your boy Cody
come out you're from Dallas Texas it's
up code sitting around waiting for
Brandon to bring that big dick energy
total energy I'll announce that date in
the meantime I debate club question for
you buddy
if time-travel existed would you rather
go back in time to experience a historic
event in the past or maybe change
something or go forward in time and see
what the future is all about love you
guys
Gang Gang buzz buzz buzz buzz brother
powerful hands man now here's the thing
I don't want jump to conclusions here
but Derek being a black man I assume you
don't want to ever go back yeah you
always want to fall forward yeah it's
bad in like 1985
yeah well white people want to go back
yeah that's a good point actually but
using more forward progress yeah black
people always want to go the future why
people want to go back and like bet on
Muhammad Ali fight and fight and make
money you know what saying yeah I got
the money or taste dessert for the first
time
go back to invent the iPhone yeah first
time I read dessert brah I remember
having dinner I'll be like all I was so
good and then somebody's like oh dinner
was good what about this over soccer
hitch yeah
over time what do they give you a
Twinkie when you're a kid or some banana
pie right Oh a nice custard Oh a nice
banana custard so [ __ ] good mmm
definitely uh I don't know the future
I'd rather I'd rather go back in time
yeah but are you gonna know what you
know now cuz I have a lot of dreams
where I go back in time and like
Undercover Boss you know I'm like
plantations and stuff like that and I'll
like have to like make sure everybody's
you know keeping in line with what's
going oh you're slave owner not a slave
owner I'm a actual employee
oh I'm Undercover Boss Oh word yeah and
you like hearing the concerns of the
yeah concerned the employees see what's
going on new music that kind of thing
just kind of ear to the grindstone you
know but so I would say I would go back
in time if I can know stuff from the
future the future looks [ __ ] sad bro
it's pretty it's a lot of people coming
in stuff at their house and mailing it
off to other people that seems like it's
a lot of people coming out their house
on robots yeah got a robot [ __ ] going
on a lot of flat earthers imagine coming
on something then there's no bad you
have to change the back there's no
batteries in it or some see you I can
empty it help yeah you know cutting that
you know sad that it's cleaning up your
[ __ ] cumdumpster of a robot oh can
you not say terms like that so I do oh
dude what if your sex robot had the lava
lamp in it so you're busting you don't
clean it up
it's a love you take out the Lovell in
and you turn yeah you take out that lava
let me just put it in your living room
put a little color in there boom dude
that's what I'm talking about watching
house as she goes you have 17 lava lamps
that's really cool I'm talking about
that boss door but I'm talking about
that bus tour that we're gonna create
bro why don't we make a bus to work you
should and let's market um Intel it
would be great to have a magical here's
the thing you're busting nuts anyways
yeah we do Austin all these stupid nuts
you idiot you're wasted on wiping up
with socks and [ __ ] in your sheet
coming and napping coming and napping ty
so hard hey imagine if you had a team
were clamping them in the lobby of your
[ __ ] apartment decorate your crib
everybody's busted out in there because
your buddy's just busting the same lamp
yeah team project I love it boss lamp
yeah dude
get your bus lamp 99s lamp and I guess
it comes with the fluid and then when
you bust it just stays in there it stays
in there but then you gotta heat it up
so those bumpy start working Oh it'll
work metal work if 50% it's 50 it's dead
for what aliens and what for a past and
future
Oh past in future wow so I guess we're
happy where we are right here in the
middle yeah that's right people happy
this next one is from Bruno from Toronto
Oh another guy come on [ __ ] what I
got a debate club for you
Game of Thrones or Avengers hmm
gang gang buzz buzz thanks so much love
the show peace this guy definitely looks
like he has a nasty shirt on and he
looks like an actual astronaut it yeah i
don'ti that was an astronaut I'd buy it
yeah there's no way he doesn't play an
astronaut or a astronauts young buddy
that's kind of like Loki shadowing him
in every movie looks like a NASA intern
no he looks like more than an intern in
serving yeah it was too young to be uh
okay but he looks like he has a shot at
going into space yeah I agree dude it
looks like Game of Thrones or adventures
and I listen man I don't [ __ ] with
Avengers i [ __ ] with the game of
Thrones you do
oh I'm balls deep in the game of Thrones
you ever seen a white Walker Theo
you ever seen a [ __ ] dragon you've
heard Clay Walker dude the [ __ ]
musician nope don't give a [ __ ] really
good you ever see her hair is long no 64
she was born either huh Khaleesi
hit on Khaleesi before that show is big
at uh you a scumbag I hit on her
appropriately first was Lindsay Lohan
now it's the queen of the Dragons dude I
put another layer in the door that said
if she was up late and bored that I was
next
hey I'm next door if you're up late and
bored I'm wide-awake next door staring
into your winner the winner here cuz no
weird that is and you're probably in a
robe what was it in a robe rather than
break what are you doing next Lindsay
Lohan she was like 17 then no she was
not seven yeah she was bro we were both
ago Yogi's [ __ ] no I even remember
looking to the IMDB of Parent Trap to
make sure there have aged yeah what are
we saying what are we even talking about
getting an app game I don't want either
one of them I'll tell you this what is
good though is just the ten of us reruns
can you bring up a picture of that just
the ten of us yeah we'll talk about one
man in [ __ ] nine hotties living in an
apartment together
you could not make this TV show today
1987
yeah can we zoom in on that are we just
gonna guess what I believe more in
dragons than I do this ball dude having
all these chicks hot chicks to row up
for debate well that's a dude on the
left there no that one is underage on
Afar bottom for now it's a dude bro
anything can happen yeah you right 1987
though you gotta stay a dude but when
you have ten kids you can [ __ ] lose a
kid bro at the mall dude you don't care
who gives off oh boy I'm more gonna be a
thicker Christmas for the rest of us if
we lose one yeah more sheets so gang
that's a great show if you get to find
those reruns yeah
I don't watch all that kind of stuff man
but if I'm gonna I'd rather see somebody
watch anything you like watch Netflix I
mean I watch Dateline really yeah I
guess Dateline what else do you do
I love missing people and I love uh they
had a show called disappear but they
couldn't find anybody else that was
missing would you like that Rana crime
drama like first 48
you look like temp do that Jax off the
Law & Order oh is that what I look like
dude no I don't what else we got it was
51% of people said Game of Thrones yeah
speaking show of all time
yep yes really yeah name clothes that's
just cuz Breaking Bad gave up Breaking
Bad was weak you know bro they shot an
infant out there I don't know I don't
breaking bad teacher selling drugs all
right I'm out yeah now it's everyone's
favorite time it's a commercial from
king in the state oh I love hellofresh
man I'll tell you right out the gate bro
yes some goals bro to 19 goals well I'll
say this not to look like it
what like a handsome young man like a
straight-up pimp pansy baby you feel me
son oh you see a food bro I'll be
working re serving Nana's bro if you
need me I'm that pimp pansy I'll say
this though if you are struggling in a
relationship or just want to spend more
time with family or anything I use
hellofresh you do I really do man if
there's somebody you haven't been able
to spend some time if I say hey come on
over let's splice up a meal together and
that's what hellofresh can do yeah but
is it is it enjoyable is it easy with
hellofresh or is it a nightmare just
take nine hours to make food these days
I thought it was gonna be a nightmare I
thought I was gonna open up the hell a
fresh box an M night Shyamalan was gonna
pop out at me but that's not the case
dude hellofresh is comfortable it makes
conquering the kitchen in 2019 a reality
all meals come to you in 30 minutes
yeah 30 minutes or less they're
deliciously simple recipes just like
Brendan Schaub himself dude what if
though I want a varieties the classic is
a veggie what about it I'm gonna feed my
family bro I got a family
they got veggie bro they got classy they
got veggie they got dual they got your
cousin whatever they want get that
hitter this spit that is just for you
all meals 30 minutes max and call for
less than two pots and pans so if that's
a minimal dish wait
shoes from classic veggie and family
with the option to switch between for
when your tastes change that's crazy get
out of the recipe rut and start cooking
they got good recipes man tight stuff
and you can get $60 off that's $20 off
your first three boxes go to hellofresh
dot-com promo code is Katz K 80s 60
hello fresh com / Katz 60 enter promo
code Katz 60 time to pay the bills I'm
gonna go this week brother me too man
I'm Phoenix we do a lot of traveling we
do a lot of traveling you know what I
don't travel anywhere without my away
suitcase bro oh I won't even go to
heaven without it brother you know when
I'm headed to see the Lord that I will
have that sweet bag with me you got to
have a sweet bag if your travel away
uses high quality materials while
offering a much lower price compared to
other brands you know why mmm they cut
out the middleman bro they cut out the
middleman you can choose from nine
colors four sizes the carry-on that's
what I mess with the bigger carry-on
that's what I got just now just got the
bigger carry-on in hunter green and it
is Phenom II know how it is drip a
drippy man the interior features a
patent-pending compression system
helpful for over packers and you know
what I'm talking about
tsa approved combination locks built in
the top of the bag so no one's stealing
your stuff no not anymore man they have
not anymore they have a removable
washable laundry bag to keep your dirty
clothes separate from your clean both
sides of the carry-on are able to charge
cell phones tablets e-readers and
anything else is powered by a u.s.
that's crazy right cord yep and right
now they offer 800 day trial dude how
about that and also lifetime warranty if
anything breaks ever they will fix it
for the rest of your life yeah think
about it they are bro you can fix it all
the way right up to the end of your life
then whenever you are ready to die you
could get buried in it dude
that's how for one yeah if that's how
long you can have it man some people
call it luggage some people call it look
casket and I caught a companion yeah 100
a trial live with it vibe with it travel
with it Instagram it whatever you want
to do for a hundred days at any point
you decide and I don't like it return it
for a full refund return it and we have
a special offer right now for $20 off
suitcase go to away travel.com / k 80s
and use promo code k 80s during checkout
that's away travel.com / k 80s promo
code k 80s yep you're gonna love it
enjoy yourself travel somewhere leave
your spouse if you want to do whatever
you want a couple of traveling pounds oh
dude I'm gonna travel homeboy you know
what I'm sayin
I'm that uh I'm that uh I can't think of
anything you're a hand yeah ma'am hey
the old bread did our next up written my
drip see it our first one is Dalton
Spice from Jacksonville Illinois gang
gang brother Wow [ __ ] look at this
little look at this little old-school
look at this little comp opportunity
looks like he's doing a reenactment for
the Civil War was the guy in charge of
sucking the boys off he looks like
straight up Swilley Wonka like he'll
take us take a swill off your rod but I
like that gold hat me - dude he looks
like a Tim Burton character that got cut
yeah he looks like calm Burton he looks
like somebody that's a Lee Burton yeah
it looks like somebody that drove over
to Tim Burton's house to bust a nut in
the driveway yeah do that a pocket watch
hell yeah it is sick look at the jeweler
look at the jewelry zoom in on that
jewelry brother cool unless you're Criss
Angel take it off no ego that's it
turquoise bra I said he made that
turquoise choice doing this when you get
all dabbed up dude I'm assuming that's
sweat there my mother wears turquoise
dude yeah my grandma stood where that
turquoise oh it's the jewelry of people
it was the nametag say he worked at some
sort of Museum or some [ __ ] cuz this is
old-school [ __ ] that's George
Washington's pocket watch here's a
nametag oh he said Main Street what is
it brewing car zoom in alright again we
say get some swag though with the
jewelery Main Street Dre Trading Co yeah
what's a pawnshop yeah man what's going
on we're gonna punch up so you work on
shop I respect that yeah hell yeah this
is fire dude I don't get why you don't
wear something like that
they have looks heavy to me up my neck
is very a lot of cerebral ish
he's Lincoln figure than us behind Abe
Lincoln fit look at the boots yeah and
it looks like he said a Hampton Inn to
which I love those boots look racist
just bury me in a Hampton Inn when I die
brother you know I'm saying wrap me up
in that deluxe suite dude I like this
guy I like this guy - what's his name
Daniel's Dalton Dalton powerful Dalton
don't you could be a racecar driver man
or a guy that delivers milk real fast to
people you think
oh yeah he'd be the fastest milkman this
side of East st. Louis it's like he
delivers lasagna mmm and I dig it I can
see that no one's doing that you don't
say oh I could see he's that [ __ ]
he's that ravioli martial artist bra
like he'll kick a [ __ ] bolognaise
right down your [ __ ] throat you crazy
Brett oh yes sorry I'm rested today I am
man you start off with Jesus with hey
sue survive and I turn this what else
shut up to this Dalton yeah I'm a
struggling up next we got a Tim Welch
from Phoenix Wow look at dim [ __ ]
jorts bro he kind of has that Joe Rogan
of the of the West vibe he was that Joe
Rogan of the future Bob dummy yeah those
[ __ ] bow lays it looks like Joe Rogan
if he if he was in that movie um what's
that movie were they were those things
climbing underground and they try to pop
out and see you Rimmer's tremors yeah
that's old movie he looks like Joe Rogan
if he's in taxicab confessions porno
yeah it looks like Joe Rogan and Hulk
oh he looks like Hulk Hogan
that's right look I get his kicks never
when Hulk Hogan's son killed somebody
with a car yeah yeah racism use uber
driver now oh yes we got leave a [ __ ]
powerful fanny pack yeah it's very
powerful and look at the front leg on
him look at the front leg months I'm
about the tear drop the quad tear drop
that's it
you know what let the fellow peloton
Rider is it that's what I think
look at the ass on him you can't see it
but you can guess what it is you got a
peach bottom out the back oh man
[ __ ] you peach cobbler brother soft area
between his ass cheek
yeah oh wow he might have that [ __ ]
rat tail hanging out the back dog oh
definitely not a moment but a rat tail
yeah oh I could see it let's zoom in on
this guy - he's got a twos he might also
be a new one I'll tell you right now he
were a lotta sysm know he [ __ ] oh
you'll take a picture like this with
confidence without [ __ ] I don't know
I could see somebody taking this and not
[ __ ] also Oh see I disagree got the
fat [ __ ] is a mini Turtles shirt on this
guy's trying too hard for me you think
is that a Lexie law let's look at his
face or is he trying that is Alexi Lalas
nevermind so that kind of says it all
remember Alexi Lalas cauliflower - does
these guy [ __ ] dude get it zoom in
power [ __ ] is that this kid [ __ ]
Stan no it's not any talk about the guy
who wrote Eminem
that's not cauliflower just a pixelated
photo you delinquent
you don't were shaped like that and
shorts like that can't choke someone
unconscious i [ __ ] with this dude I bet
you guys his black belt - and [ __ ]
snap your neck yeah like there's a
little crawfish you snapped over the
weekend oh dude I put one of them one of
them tapped out dude my patch like give
up just yeah suck the head feed the
tails yeah I can't look at this man
anymore I mean it looks like a nice man
but I'm tired of looking at him right
now
power power moves though up next we got
a James Dawson from Northampton Shire
England okay just dirty national oh hell
yeah brother this is me this is me right
here what you mean I'm just saying if I
were in England this would be me - this
kind of person I think so man he's a
little more beefier than you a little
more manly really look he he looks like
Sabretooth like a young saber-tooth from
x-men movie dude you look like Billy
Elliot Roasters started a [ __ ]
Anytime Fitness cool huh
he's Billy bring up a picture of Billy
Elliot real quick if you don't mind
Derrick's really great on the computer
isn't he
I've never owned a computer in my life
so thank you let's get Billy Elliot an
image of him Billy Elliot is like kind
of like the Christopher Columbus of like
a way of whales this kid yeah not a poof
top
right now both dog you know a couple I
expect that a guy listen to yellow off
um yellow one of the top probably eleven
rappers of all time dude
I expect that out of you homeschool flat
earther that's fine
70s have any to tow truck drivers listed
in a [ __ ] yellow wolf no but you
better get your mind up no doubt bro you
better mind up in desert I'm just saying
you look like Billy elevate Billy Elliot
opened up a smoothie shop outside huff
outside of [ __ ] manager this guy
looks like the muscle for some [ __ ]
oh yeah this looks like Michael Bisping
at a young age doesn't it Donna in awake
a little bit don't take any [ __ ] like he
didn't want to take this picture he
looked like it hey wait the guy who took
the picture look at him
this guy looks like he's beat that like
he drinks tea and beats what he does
dude he looks like a little like a spot
of tea and then just beat the living
[ __ ] there's not enough sugar and
there's beating the [ __ ] out of it oh
he'll teabag a whole nation bro
this guy looks like teabag or a
superhero in in in in Britain I don't
want to [ __ ] with this guy what else we
got dude this guy will definitely he'll
Markel Megan if you know what I'm saying
King Charles starting look like a
straight [ __ ] bro let's be honest to
who tracks which ones Prince Charles
which ones Prince they both look like
[ __ ] but ya know when I was in the
war but one of them has just been a mean
War One Flew Over the woman okay but
then he's like on battle-tested [ __ ]
you're in a bulletproof jet with 17
other dudes but I love you England my
mom's from there did you really yeah bro
born and raised Wow I could see that a
little bit yeah make raised to broke
morning days bro hey now to the Queen
yeah you don't know a globe works how
are the Queen bro don't go to England
huh
don't go to I'm warning line what I'm
going England should it yeah well well
you gotta get my approval
go ahead Nick makedonia from Fort
Lauderdale oh dude I love your nuts bro
what's up the only one key of my
Florida and I need some relationship
advice what's up bro there's this girl
I've been talking to for a few months
now she's been giving me some signals
signe wants it pause it
that's what you did first of all don't
say wants it let's hear him saying it
well for atomic cuz I really love this
guy mr. Mac at 9:00 yet he was all
naughty boys wanted to for a few months
now she's been giving me some signals do
you think about this guy out of the gays
you know as somebody who's uh let's just
say has beef with aliens okay you think
about a guy who a regular white
earthling who says that girls like girl
like what do you do what's your thoughts
on Nick makedonia I think before he says
some girl what one city she could have
his mom's living room I mean I was kind
of feeling him he seemed nice at first
right and do you went throwing me signs
cuz she won't well he said the girls
sending out signals which I also agree a
lot of times girls and use signals like
they'll leave their apartment early and
go to work which I'll take is a signal
sometimes or you'll see a girl take her
trash out late at night well why should
she be and you think oh she's in the
same things I am
yeah yeah or you'll see all the radio
and you're like we're the same yes yeah
yeah yeah you'll see that she gets a lot
of the same type of mail that you get
and so there's a lot of ways to tell you
know a lot of signals from women out
there hard to shift through all of it oh
it's hard to ship through it like
sometimes they'll play hard to get
they'll drive home and they'll just
drive right into there and they'll
they'll get out of their car walk
straight into their house without
looking over at you yeah which isn't
cool when you're in the bush all God
doesn't cool let me at least acknowledge
on there but it's our very cool way and
I kind of like that yeah hard to get you
know sometimes you go in the house so
well uh well we'll start with some uh
some advice after he after he asked from
Derek and Kat let's see what you guys
have for this young man he has a
boyfriend who she's been with quite a
while now couple years four or five
something like that nothing he's too
lazy and uh you know we talk a lot and
stuff and I'm just really [ __ ]
confused because
mm-hmm coño if she likes me if she likes
him she tells me she has doubts in that
relationship and I don't know what to do
should I just let her let it go you know
I'm kind of wait and do my own thing or
should I should I tell her what I feel
or I'm not really sure what to do
anyways uh let me know Gang Gang buzz
buzz Co see you April 26 West Palm Beach
gang buzz buzz gay this weekend um let's
start with a ladies perspective Kat well
she definitely doesn't want to be with
her boyfriend anymore no I'll tell you
about now yeah you're just an easy-out
honestly yeah you just need a reason
he's out yeah he's the outlet if it's
not him it might be somebody else no she
just what she'll want either of them
she's talkin to homeboy the past time to
something nice come swimming along so
he's just a bookmark he's not really
should he make a move on her I mean if
he's ready for the mess that ensues I
mean her boyfriend may come after the
mess you mean in his pants cat no she's
talking about an actual human
interaction you creep Derek get in there
bro bro unless you unless you boys with
them if your boys with that guy not cool
it's not like he knows yeah yeah I'd
offer that macadamia bro you know I'm
saying I'd drop a little you know I just
come in hot - yeah I pull my pants down
yeah
such an old-school move you okay no dude
you're just you just see you see where
you're at that's right now it's blurry
get to [ __ ] out well here's the thing
what Luisi came people I want to say
this the women weren't interested he
came in the plant you know I'm saying I
thought it was thoughtful I thought it
was the most green way to sexually kind
of infuriate someone you defuse the
situation yeah oh you don't want this
I'll give it back maybe you had a
[ __ ] lava lamp yeah some lady's
getting it mother nature someone got it
yeah imagine putting that into a lava
lamp though and entertaining your
friends for decades to come
imagine passing your bust lamp your your
bust orb on to your children - in it
took years to complete dad is this all
your semen dad
it's me and my money there at the hole
hope I return the lamp anybody oh cool
anybody okay
don't make me get that guy who had a
strippers drip on your ass - Michael
Bisping early Bisping the bully
we had the bully uh this guy dude the
lines are blurry she's not into either
from he's just an outlet you see what's
up I think he's a nice man he obviously
Shops at Pottery Barn if he got that
type of pillow with that uh different
type of style on it he's little lazy
though he is that posh we just got done
busting nuts and he's just like let me
make a video for these boys he's all
like yes it's very energy going on yeah
it's very leaving Neverland of him yeah
I agree which I hate to you know remind
you at different times in your life but
let's move on what do I know dude up
next for a relationship advice we got
Aaliyah this is this is Lea yo gang gang
someone having trouble with my best
friend where were my best friend I slept
with her boyfriend mm-hmm so we are kind
of into it yeah yeah why are you trying
to apologize to her she's not listening
should I still keep apologizing or
should I just let it go it's been a
month now since we hold of each other so
well I'm sorry you're going through this
Aaliyah
uh that one Aaliyah died so you're doing
better than her you better her and I'll
say this is well young lady that um you
just can't apologize on her time like
you can't apologize on your timeline you
got to apologize on her timeline so you
might have to give us some space and
then apologize again find a different
way to apologize send a mail hey can we
get can we address those she [ __ ] her
best friends man
she's not a victim sorry for I don't
feel sorry for her but I understand that
she's trying to apologize she just wants
to apologize month oh shoot I'm like
yeah you right let's lift it back and
[ __ ] go to Disneyland girl right
she's not gonna so she need Shakya you
can't apologize fast apologize takes a
long time it takes you know an actual
commitment to it it takes a commitment
to someone to prove to them that you
feel bad about what happened
if you burn down somebody's [ __ ] you
know LaVon Duryea or whatever washing
washeteria then they're [ __ ] pissed
bro you know and you gotta [ __ ]
apologize to him over years you gotta
pay them back dude and it's it's a big
time you'll [ __ ] somebody's best friend
though you know it's tough yeah it is
probably you're not gonna have a
friendship with her no it's probably
over huh for maybe this lifecycle but
you can build you know I'm the next life
Oh reincarnation [ __ ] I'll see
you again yeah might come back as
elephants yeah is cool yeah next time
you're not gonna [ __ ] stampede on her
man no yeah sure peanuts yeah you're
gonna be [ __ ] yeah next time if you're
yeah the only thing will be sharing his
peanuts so that's what I would say I
would say look this life I [ __ ] up she
seems sorry though doesn't she she seems
a little down it's pretty lady
she's pretty lady man but she seems also
like she might [ __ ] somebody's [ __ ]
and her friend's boyfriend yes it
appears huh yeah so that's you know
there's that too
you know what kind of turns me on I bet
she's gonna I've been teasing me all
right in life I thought she's gonna be
fine well dude you also were you won the
you won the Never Land her hands [ __ ] it
you're sticking on the Michael Jackson
look you were actually molested as a
child my pears let the [ __ ] out of me
no one touched my dick no was he really
scouts nobody believes you my scouts bro
nobody leaves you crazy wigger bro
you're [ __ ] dressing like a
psychopath yeah you have tattooed it
looks like you're sponsored by the
goodwill what are you talking about it's
a nice shirt the WNBA gave you their
clothes haha this is a cotton shirt you
good yeah whatever ro but what are you
talking about dude bro you look like a
dude that referee bro you look like a
referee at a [ __ ] swim meet in
Jacksonville dude I'll take look
horrible dude you need new friends but
you you need to not get Nick's approval
on the way you dress and you're both
creeps
you have another creep tell you you look
good yeah small hat gang but why don't
you [ __ ] get a hat that fits you why
don't you get a haircut that's relevant
to a 19 this is a good
haircut it's only two weeks old all
right what else you got up next we're
gonna do flaunt my aunt bring it
start with aunt Jan me Smith on Jamie
Smith Oh back on this [ __ ] merchants
finest oh yeah bro that's just my damsel
then tip the dustbowl bad girl bro I
remember her you seem like somebody rien
barbecue bad girl
oh dude of Meissen maybe I'll bust on
yes yes bro just from the 1930s bro
tango and hey Chinna nem bro I am
whatever you say I am I'm staying up in
that age yeah this is Stan bruh
um what's up with this girl she's a
modelling attractor yeah this is Aunt
Jenny Smith she just recovered from
heart surgery oh man she's got a lot of
love to give
dude look I'll let you look I'll let you
I'll never jump right you a John Deere
letter I promise you that beautiful lady
out here and obviously hanging out in
the lobby of a Cracker Barrel will they
let you do this type of stuff or they'll
let you dress up and Jenny Smith
obviously named after the apples which
were right on the wall behind her is
that a apple can we zoom out the other
way huh she does look like a free spirit
with a good heart sell you some apples
maybe a little weed on the side yes you
go hippie vibe huh yep she's got that
hippie vibe that Georgia hippie vibe she
also looks like she could possibly
moonlight as a Bret Michaels you know
show up at parties at children's parties
and stuff senior well Bret Michaels what
was his big jam we both lie silently
deal indeed
night all the songs name bang all those
frickin are like the love oh you know
there's a new one with the Jersey Shore
boys no way yeah it's called sex crimes
van I forget what it's called I forget
what's the Jersey Shore boys
it's basically rock a love but with
[ __ ] Jersey Shore
yeah but Pauly Shore is a black face in
these days or whatever that guy's Halle
lay off the Tanner pop what are you just
[ __ ] injecting chocolate milk in your
cheeks that guy's getting a little dark
these days double shot at love yeah
might be something worth checking out
for us but yeah I love this I love the
Bret Michaels vibe congratulations on
the new way orders and you just rock
those [ __ ] love sockets and just keep
them popping huh yeah veins girl
pump pump Gang Gang you feel me that vas
deferens bro you know what I'm saying
that Venus Fly Trap that long winning
your neck go up next we got grandpa Pete
this is grandpa Pete I mean Danny DeVito
first of all this guy looks like every
character from an 80s movie I feel like
in one person Danny DeVito he was
hunting he looks like daddy Shaq bro
this dude looks like every character him
daddy Shaq and one person they combine
it all he characters he looks like a
nice guy in the whole world where is he
in Iowa he looks like a cell you Minos
he does well it looks like he'll sell
you minnows right out of his stomach
dude like I swear to god he could just
put one of those big spoons into himself
what do we have any facts on this day
loves fishing golfing and watching TV
then hello we just labeled his whole
life cash at he likes to live in bro
yeah oh this guy looks like an organ
donor dude like he just cut you off a
piece of his own liver right there and
put it into you it's gonna be good to
you know the liver is one of the only
regenerative and that's not a racial
slur it's one of the only regenerative
organs you know that you could cut your
liver in half give half of it to someone
give half of it to cat and it would grow
back you know grow back for you it'll
grow back for her I didn't know that yep
so you can liver so if you're dying or
somebody's dying don't eat all their
liver eat a little bit of it in Latin
or grow back shout out to Danny DeVito
though doing the damn thing yeah this
guy seemed like he could definitely stir
grandpa he looks more like an uncle
Oh a diploma grandpa oh I bet you could
pull a needle right out of his piss
stream dude this guy seems like a real
[ __ ] Saint Bernard of a human and I
like it so he owns leeches what else you
got our last one is Misha Misha from
magna Utah
oh she enjoys eating wet burritos and
loves that 70s show is that a sexual
term what's a whip you know I think it's
a burrito covered in their sauce oh you
talk about that burrito that's covered
like tostada style I think for enchilada
style yes they put the enchilada sauce
on top than the cheese what burrito
sounds super sexual does it yeah bro I
get that wet burrito girl yeah okay
that's a pick-up line if you do wet
burrito Cleveland steamer
yeah two totally different meals brother
oh yeah
you're disgusting yeah she also
considers herself Smith what is that a
single mom I'd like to oh wow yeah oh
okay that's a showing it show time in it
smells I think so
and what were the Smurfs dude single why
was it called maybe they were that was a
blue cult the Blue Man Group is a cult
ah this ant looks like she's in some
[ __ ] the dark arts as you would say
it was like she likes magic she looks
like she likes black things
oh she look like she'll [ __ ] do it
Debra Kadabra brought like show hit take
a hard dab and [ __ ] anybody in the house
dude I shouldn't say that actually she
seems like a nice lady man she's a she's
a clean apartment or clean home she has
two dog bowls right there in the back so
she's feeding them kind of dogs she had
those look like human balls well my big
those bowls are maybe her dogs like
cereal dude maybe she has Dobermans
maybe she have Saint Bernards mm good
point okay and she's obviously the kind
of lady that works hard she has uh she's
25 yeah enjoys wet burrito 70s show that
show doesn't run anymore I like her
though she has her own style kind of
because what 25 year old was watching
that 70 show I don't blame you though
there's a lot of bad television now so
why not watch a good television
bad stuff out there [ __ ] yeah I mean I'm
not mad at her aunty oh dude I would
probably take her somewhere nice what's
her name again Derek Magna she's in Utah
Utah girl you take her the red iguana no
she's from magna Utah her name's Aisha
and she's really tall why did he see her
Izzy I thought her name was magna
graecia Anisha
and he should all right well you need to
take her to red iguana in Utah bro yeah
the best wet burritos in the lane they
do yeah shout to Salt Lake City I'll
take your hands yeah sheshe my kind of
girl you would maybe take abroad take
her to a foreign country take her to the
Filipinos take a look she don't have a
nose out there bro take her to dark you
know white take out a can or a white
Canada some people call it I don't know
take her to [ __ ] where Cleveland to
the UM no you need to take her the
[ __ ] dog track somewhere where do
women like to go these days I don't know
I've been on a date in so long
Lego and Legoland yeah yeah take her to
Legoland and stack that ass up he'll
kill me I'm just joking and I shouldn't
say got wet burrito is there a problem
no they don't but you quit saying wet
burritos I can't did such an interesting
detail wet burrito oh I agree the second
it's a sexual term [ __ ] buddy now yeah
who wants that do you want me to wait
yeah no guy can you quit smiling do it
so it's so clever Mike it's code word
bro a pizza gate I know it is I can't
believe you're so shocked I just never I
did wet your burrito bro I can't believe
you're so shocked by a good stratiform
bro she's trying to [ __ ] she has
children already and two dogs she has
enough to deal with health dude yeah
[ __ ] is enough to deal with dude you're
even thinking about that you're trying
to [ __ ] this lady I think she's the one
that wants the wet-nosed oh yes I can I
think she's a beautiful lady and best of
luck to you out there
shoutout to you Tom magna carta last
segment boys a king understand all right
first one comes from an Elise Mortimer
and her dog Marley from British Columbia
Canada that's what I'm saying
let's take a little video love you
what's up Doug girl buzzbuzz buzzbuzz
yeah I'm hockey bro you got the hockey
haircut do what if first of all and
thank you for saying that
people sometimes say mullet this mullet
that Eric Lindros yeah bro here's what I
say your mother okay because the deal is
this in Canada this hockey are cut in
Philippines this is a [ __ ] this is a
[ __ ] you're a blonde woman in
different places settle files haircut
yeah dude but it depends where you're at
but a top-notch pedophile bra no not
like a low-level yeah I know scammers
bro and I'm saying not somebody who's
just hot raising minnows in their snow
not a Backpage Craig now you're talking
about a champion here's what I would
love to think today is that I do like
hockey and I love Canadians and I have a
feeling as America turns more into a
Airport for the rest of the world that a
lot of Americans will become Canadians
and move up there so I hope to see you
guys soon in the beautiful dog Marley
was the dog's name
Marley here's the thing with hockey
raices is [ __ ] hockey everyone
encourages the white guys to fight all
the time but in then be a few black guys
fighting their thugs but every goddamn
night in NHL someone's getting knocked
out Oh what's name [ __ ] Ola Lin Chi
we're the number one hockey player in
the world just knocked out some 19 year
old everyone celebrated it yeah then you
get in one little tiff and the NBA and
their thugs
well that's true mom with it broke also
NHL football on ice yeah why do UFC
fighters on ice is it oh yeah very
violent out there and super violent we
just [ __ ] with it yeah hard sport in the
world dawg give me that but look then I
would like to see this then hockey
players against black people against
aliens on ice yes
mmm with a ball out there too on ice
white dudes own that [ __ ] aliens you
know what they're gonna [ __ ] do you
idiot I'm gonna
zooom the white guys don't you think
hailey is gonna come all the way here
and then not beat everyone not on ice I
know how nice that's a good point given
too much respect that's true dude I
think
oh speaking of a hockey what about this
dude here's a picture of him Brady thick
a chick as a legend they said this guy
fake-ass rat Kings out oh he's called
himself the Rat King
yeah hey Brady taco chip whatever the
[ __ ] your name is
come at us bro yeah come at us we own
that name dude well people said he's
decent they said he they got a brother
or whatever the little one is the little
rat that place for the UM Calgary and I
love Calgary man best crowd they saw the
best comedy crowd great tom how Yuk
Yuk's but yeah they got the dude the
little guy called himself to her though
you know the younger brother or whatever
and I told him he can come get these
straight up seeming pinatas under my
meat brother if you want him you know
what I'm [ __ ] hands one rat King up
in here bro I didn't say that I said
come get these nuts daddy yeah I'm
saying come get these hands you heard of
us saying saying and Calgary lost they
lost four games in a row to the
Avalanche bro
Colorado Avalanche bro what your [ __ ]
that's where you're from yeah ABS
country baby avalanche a launch yeah uh
for sure take that shirt off and also I
King hockey though you can sport the
world yeah I do too our king hockey -
man those are tough tough guys always
thought you can fight and no one gets a
[ __ ] felony strip the [ __ ] out of
each other that's true the racking is a
land animal though also Wayne Gretzky
come on yeah did you see his daughter Oh
bro you're on it today today you go to
church more often I will what else we
got is whoa Hannah Hannah Debus from San
Diego
Hannah Daboo what's her name Rose hit
Tanya Hannah
de buf Hannah Montana Debussy but I go
to school in Phoenix
and a student nurse my king interesting
it or you guys is gross with ABS oh my
god what'd she say
put your phone away she wants a child I
couldn't hear it for a little bit
oh no what is she doing Oh rewind up for
me that is dogs we getting your boner
yeah well she looked after you go oh my
god
before that rewind me it's my decent
amount if you don't mind Eric I can't
interesting it for you guys is gross
with that kind of cute too much no what
you think I think both wrong that she
hits that vaping no she's sucking it
sucking that bait bro shit's hard for
you so [ __ ] lonely I know I do you
just wanna bust no I don't I wanna hug
somebody you want to hug her with ABS
yeah I want to watch Dateline together
with someone and be glad that we're
still alive because somebody else got
murdered there's people who do that free
to I don't know if she's the type but
there's a mean guy she takes care of
herself
look at her apartments clean you know
what the problem is you're too soft for
her you know I'm saying like you do you
- you think so yeah - jello she's nearly
think that or not yeah I do she's ripped
it'd be like sleeping with a [ __ ]
Panther oh wow we're hugged a panther
just [ __ ] [ __ ] diesel muscle Panthers
are only violent on camera and stuff you
see them behind the scenes they're
pretty chill they're docile yeah she
seemed like a nice lady a registered
nurse she said her traveling nurse no
she's all right yeah I think it's cool
to be a registered nurse so you know she
can take care you don't cut my leg open
right here with a [ __ ] scalpel just
to get her to stop by I'm not gonna be a
Phoenix huh
yeah Phoenix isn't that fall I'm going
to Phoenix on Friday I'm gonna pass out
are you really this yeah I should hold
my breath do get along get that
secondhand CPR for me you feel me yeah
I'll tell you what's her name Ramona
Hannah Dan is same lifestyle oh you're
disgusting
I'm sorry Hannah on behalf of Brendon no
don't be girl meeting here could talk
about [ __ ] working on she talk about
everyone
at night yeah talking with Brennan's
really great dude he has a [ __ ] word
chart with like 30 words on it just show
signs yeah you call your mom to approve
the sign from home school dude two reps
of disturbing though do you know you
don't want a girl more ripped than you
are yeah you don't want it calluses on
her hands she should be under arrest for
disturbing the beast bro cuz my wiener
woke up when I saw this yeah what was
she asking us about River drip I think
you look okay no she was saying she was
saying is girls who are too shredded
like ABS oh to shredded is insane if
you're all [ __ ] jacked if you have a
mole on your neck that's also as mussels
coming out of it get that [ __ ] yeah [ __ ]
Michael B Jordan you know like to
shredded I don't want to hug somebody
and come in second you feel me worse so
you got a tie I mean tighten up and
loosen up just be cool just do what you
want to do just be genetically gifted
though some girls are just genetically
[ __ ] shredded and it's just ABS I
just don't like a girl that eyes like
ABS on her on her be whole you know what
I'm saying yes just ABS yeah you can't
be that you can't have abs in a [ __ ] you
know I'm saying like you had a pig don't
work out so hard you start sprouting a
straight route you feel me yeah see or
more yeah next up is shout out to that
girl though right yeah you pervert we
got it you're the one every wanting to
have had a boner officer that's
something natural that happens in your
body you talk to your therapist next is
from Blake this videos from Blake
Presley south of Knoxville Tennessee
look at that boat motor in the
background did he kill so many fish
Brandon CEO this is Blake from Knoxville
Tennessee I think everybody should have
a hobby so I've got a king under stinger
for you fast fishing there's now brandon
schauer
before you jump to that we're gonna
learn Joe there's a lot more to it than
that maybe you want to pitch that G
maybe you want to skip that toad
educator bribe you walk that spoke on
top water walk that spook that's racist
so is pitch that jig you peg and shake
that board hitter
okay great dude he educate us on some
[ __ ] deep-sea fishing baby dude that
guy will catch a second wife have you
owned one of those things man that dude
has some ranch a body in that lake right
now knows all too much about it bro you
go fishing in Florida man you'll come up
with a large-mouth deceased person dude
they got a lot of wildlife out there
catch them Dexter bodies in Florida
that's a Dexter belt over here Florida
you know most episodes of first 48 or
filmed in Florida yeah and also that's
where it inspired Dexter yeah so it's
the murder country but hell yeah man
there's a document bass fishing is
beautiful man it's a real art you got to
get out I have been bass fishing man
I've been regular fishing have you it's
a long day yeah it's a long day if
you're not good it's just you and your
buddies staring at the water I mean it
ain't it ain't Instagram it's the total
opposite of Instagram you know yeah
you're not gonna get satisfaction like
this right it's out there you gonna
allow it
you can complain you know five or six
hours into it there's a you know there's
a little bit of window for homosexuality
if you want it they got it Roger on the
boat you're good
they have drinkin they have everything
you want out there so you can really get
out there and enjoy yourself sunburn you
get a year's worth of Sun right there
and one after I would go with him I go I
was a pro he seems fun he does him in
the front I'm was in Randy Moss fishing
Invitational one time as bass fishing
and I had a diarrhea that that day never
get you and I didn't know that once you
got on the boat you're out there for the
entire time so you have to hold the
shit's bro you say come in the waters oh
dude at one point I had to have them
hang me off the back of the fish from
the water I didn't have any choice yeah
it's Chum the water [ __ ] bro the guys
like I just kept saying let's go to the
restroom the guy was like I'll just piss
off the back of the boat man you know
like now you got a piss on me yeah I
piss out my anus yeah I gotta do a thick
one out of them you know cam so you did
it everyone just hell had to I literally
had to take off all my clothes and hand
off the boat it was a real fishing
tournament like somebody won like like a
$60,000 okay [ __ ] best of the Fisher's
up I know there was tons of lakes in
Minnesota out there Lake Minnetonka and
it was uh I met Roy Jones jr. now that's
cool it's pretty cool DFC to you then
don't know uh you seem good
probably 13 years ago is straight
fishing Canyon hell yeah boys all right
next up we got drew Dawson from Topeka
Kansas seems like a for our show today
huh Game of Thrones nine I don't think
so we're not that long no yo what up
Thea what up Brendan my name is drew
from Topeka Kansas I saw a girl big fan
of this show Jayhawk love I got a king
distinguished Rajah first off let me
thank y'all for helping me get through
my day sometimes man
when I'm at work I work a little factory
gig man and I just set up the phone and
run some king of sting get fighter in
the kid this past weekend and it makes
ours feel like minutes love it man so I
appreciate y'all for that this Jayco is
is beautiful
anyway my question for y'all today is
polyamorous relationships three people
is involved in a relationship together
whether that be two girls one guy two
guys one girl depending on what state
you're from it could be two cousins and
a nephew
I don't know but it could be three dude
polyamorous relationship kangaroo sting
yeah couldn't be also I would say put a
woman in there if you're even
guesstimating but you do what you gotta
do burn it three dudes Brendan they call
him two rivers three dudes two rivers
it's gonna say on your freakin - ah I
just feel like it's so Massey man you
know anyone who's in a polyamorous
relationship just doing the damn thing
thriving
I don't yeah I mean look I think it
takes a lot of communication you know
back in the day they used to have a
polyamorous relationship you have to did
it yeah look at the Mayflower to Penta
do you [ __ ] whoever's alive on there you
know so it's like anything was possible
I think if you know anyone doing it
these days though like just doing the
damn thing I did look I'll tell you this
I had a guy come to my show recently and
he had two girlfriends that was it and
they were both cool with each other and
everybody was chill and it was a just a
loving community you know and I believed
it with this I think as long as there's
clear communication because sometime
it's like what are we you drawn the line
against real
you know if somebody if you can still
love someone but I don't [ __ ] know do
it I'm [ __ ] lonely and I'm a
medication also so kids to girls see how
it goes man be the guinea pig oh I know
how it'll go man
you know it'll go fine for a girl and a
dude the way you you know know all right
I'm just spitballing ideas here bro you
seem lonely and sad yeah think of other
ideas fast you are two dudes I don't
know what you're into listen if you can
pull it off [ __ ] yeah if you can't it's
gonna be a nightmare the pros and cons
pros you [ __ ] two different girls all
the time so fun cons you got two chicken
heads harassing you all the now I'm just
drama drama drama pros cons what
happened where are you where am I yeah
here's what I say dude can you bust two
nuts a day
Oh sometimes it's tough I can trust you
not so weak yeah you older first of all
[ __ ] anybody seems like totally
outlandish these days that Ray rather do
some PlayStation or do something more
energy you hate burning calories well
dude I just don't want to be [ __ ]
somebody bang bang bang bang bang
you know mmm then you have to eat or get
a drinker or a milk or something see
this is why I say get a food I don't
want a dude I don't want to [ __ ] anybody
you idiot
I just said that didn't not [ __ ] some
goddess for no reason it's gonna do it
and play playstation I would maybe do
that you should do the big brother thing
what is it it's where you get a big
brother you just plays PlayStation with
you like once a week or some [ __ ]
you know her that it's a black guy good
if you want I would do it
get a big brother huh you could do it
we'll find your bad guy yeah I say King
it though if you can handle it I don't
want some white brother dude I don't
want Jason Williams hanging out of my
house all day
no I bubble spartina I don't want
[ __ ] yeah I don't want Paul Wall or
Bill Clinton [ __ ] hanging out with me
all day dude you know what I'm saying I
mean shout out to some legit Whigs out
there but still man anyway
drew Dawson drew Dawson man thank you
very much man I'm glad that we were able
to entertain you dude
we do try our best when we get in here
you try man
and I say the communication is the key
if you can just be honest about it and
let them know what's going on cuz here's
the thing I think some people that are
equipped to love others can really do a
good job of it you know you might be
able to you might have the gift of being
able to love to people well whereas some
mother [ __ ] jerk-off like old [ __ ]
you know cinnamon Wilson over here
[ __ ] Michael Jackson's little you
know lava lamp over here you've been
therapy sink you were for brain you
can't get a [ __ ] connection with
another human being
dude get a [ __ ] owl hang out with an
owl
oh are you something owls are fake bro
if you look under their skirt they don't
have a lot of meat on them all right but
yeah man I say king of where we was he
asked I say king of boy I don't know
anyone who's not successful other than
Hugh Hefner I think he was miserable
right I think he was old but his was all
about the sex I think if you can find
some Joey in there too you know then you
can figure it out better know anyone
who's doing I think we're on the cusp of
it though dude things change you know
things go and change so the guy who's
alone at night yeah whatever dude
at least I don't have some Sun always
bother me a two-year-old son yeah that's
one way to look at it sorry never mind
man he's a beautiful kid
yeah praise God yeah bro
you had the Jesus you started with the
Jesus juice and ended with a Satan juice
yep that's hitman and I'm sorry I know
it was a probably in a negative attitude
today man I'm sorry if I was rude no
it's just you in general that could be
we appreciate you bro
Thank You Canada [ __ ] be Bruce what I'm
saying dude you should talk to you to
khabib let me know how it goes for you
oh yeah do you know I hope they bully
you
dude I bought [ __ ] HGH from his
entourage dude at the other one part of
the dagestanis mancom from Kingston
March drops this Friday I'm in Phoenix
Friday and Saturday stand up live deal
where are you at brother I'm in West
Palm Beach this weekend I think they're
still tickets actually I think it's sold
out but also dropping dates this week by
the end of this week we'll be dropping
some new dates for Vancouver Boise
Sacramento a couple of different places
and I will let um yeah I'll let
everybody know where uh where listeners
can get the tickets first so I'm in
Tampa and Cleveland to this month all
right guys
yup yeah thank you love you get some
king of the sting merch and ah and thank
you guys so much for your support peace